well a couple a couple updates a couple
updates here on we spoke about this a
little bit yesterday if you want to hear
a little more in depth than like I said
revenge of assist.locals.com but
um we were talking about
um sex trafficked victim
which what name are we using now she has
a lot of names was Eliza blue is he is
it blue Diddy puff puff blue what are we
calling I've thrown up my new name for
nomination Eliza strikes
uh um I'm looking at her uh social blade
we could call her Eliza red oh okay fair
enough I like that yeah
um so how about Eliza go the [__] away
how about how about Eliza through her
teeth that's that's a good one too God
damn it pessy why is he so [__] good
he's Jewish Eliza is Fleshlight
now that doesn't narrow it down that
doesn't narrow it down as much as you
think
newest flashlight there that's not bad
um so she had that music video we
actually played some of it yesterday
um the one that she claimed she was sex
trafficked the world star one well guess
what
it was Worldstar took it down themselves
right is that what happened no no no no
no no no no no she hit it with a privacy
claim wait what yeah yeah actually hey
Royce you know the the thing that they
use specifically to protect actual
survivors of sex trafficking and people
who are actually being exploited yeah
having the father having a father yeah
yeah exactly well not that anyways so
yeah she used that system it says
specifically on the video this video has
been pulled for a due to a third-party
copy or a privacy uh claim well that's
unfortunate
fortunately as MERS pointed out on
Twitter
the Streisand Effect is something that
she really needs to look into
yeah right
um because the problem is is that I uh I
don't know virgin I don't know if you
noticed but your yours is the one that's
been going around Twitter
um yeah
Virgie decided that uh
no problem I'll upload it
there it is it's on his channel if you
want to see it and guess what we're not
on YouTube so go ahead and try special
girl come on
[Music]
so now now she is hitting by the way
privacy claims very rarely hold up we'll
find out in three days that's about how
long it takes for the Privacy claim I'll
give a privacy claim you were in the
video no no I know but because we've
dealt with privacy plans with complaints
before YouTube in blocks first
and then you know take this questions
later basically that's how it works and
sometimes they don't ask questions they
just leave it
um so
she uh
didn't she say she got paid 150 000 for
sex she turned down she said turned down
150 000 for sex proud of it because
she's gross now what what years did
Virgie you know well but Marsh and
Virgie both know so I'll ask both of you
what years did she say she was sex
trafficked said she was uh
I think I think the years it depends on
[__] when she's saying it it changes
it's like it's like it's like nebulous
it's like the Joker's origin it changes
all depends on which writer exactly it
starts around 2000 uh depending on the
story 2000 2001 2002 and it ends around
2009 in every story
so
question now you pointed this up she has
she has she has a couple different names
I brought that up at the beginning
um why why was that
why why does she have a couple names
yeah why be that okay well um well you
see most women most women who are born
with like their father's name well let's
use for this case uh Northland uh most
women who are born with their father's
names
tend to keep their father's names until
they get married
oh see that oh wait what is this
oh oh this is a this is this is divorce
this is divorce paperwork right here
Royce
if I'm doing the math she was actively
getting sex trafficked and at least some
of her stories while she was married
Yes actually yes as a matter of fact she
was being trafficked while she was
married
well if you so if you consider her
version of what trafficking is then yes
that's right fake Instagram accounts as
we brought up yesterday if you have a
fake Instagram account it's fake
Instagram account or sorry fake Twitter
accounts that are somehow you know tied
to actual Instagram accounts kind of
weird right that means merch is the most
sex trafficked man on Earth
wow isn't that awesome yeah that's right
maybe if the hotel crew could kick in a
cup you know I'm saying come on now
now you like as you brought up so she
was uh she was married at the time
hey this is a fun one sure her she filed
for divorce or no sorry he filed for
divorce that sounds better no six and oh
six the same year that she did blind
date and went and did [__] all those
other appearances and
[__] right no six
has somebody
has somebody got the blind date videos
yeah we have the blind date is she
really good in it
oh she's very good they love her
actually she's oh yeah videos
yeah if you don't mind I haven't I
honestly don't mind like a couple I
haven't seen it so so we're we're
blinded connoisseurs Royce I love
blinding like why are they something you
know her that I used to watch as a kid
like oh come on you know yeah yeah yeah
blind date was just next levels The
Producers on blind date were very mean
uh wow
150 dollars maybe Eliza come on 150. you
fell asleep with their finger on the
Zero button tell me when they're in
their Verge or just send it directly to
me
um oh thank you he did it's there sorry
buddy
all right here we go
I love it let's move on this is a
[__] good one it's a Rock and Roll
Lifestyle she says she's pretty exciting
but I'm trying to find a high quality
version I don't care this is still good
hold on I don't care what quality it is
so good
I'm a self-seeking self-centered and
fear-based
are you now
Ariana now was she getting sex traffic
during blind date
uh I think I think everybody was
perpetually sex trafficked wait
everybody was getting sexual everybody
was getting sexual wow getting sex
trafficked everywhere there you go and I
have high expectations as far as sex
goes she has a shirt that says it's sex
traffic a clock somewhere
don't talk to me until I've had my sex
traffic
live laugh sex traffic
so when John did one of these was he sex
yes yes
Frozen I don't know if you know this
you're being sex trafficked right now as
we speak hey I already knew that hey
a Frozen
all sex trafficking
[Laughter]
I changed my [__] biology
Survivor an advocate good good you see
what you see what you did Eliza you
happy now
you know how many more victims you just
made by expanding the definition of it
laughs
about the hair
um it was black one
oh I'm sure a lot of things were
and it was blue and pink I think it'd be
it can be really sexy and it just takes
a certain type of guy to appreciate it
well who better to appreciate Eliza than
her date Mike he's an artist who says
that when he's not in the studio he's
living life in the fast lane nice
bro she is like kind of mid too right
like she's not even that good looking no
look at them titties look at him titties
and tell me those are good titties
look at them titties and tell me those
are good titties
she got quacking titties
working
what do I do I hang out with friends go
to the pool
go to the gym
so what do you spend uh most of your
time
on Twitter
[Laughter]
you know I tweet about a lot of sex
driving stuff I don't actually do
anything yeah but what is it you do
merch you know the problem is you're
just so mean
s I'm an [__] you're such an [__]
bud
Now's the Time to remind you guys of my
Maya Abuelita beans
foreign
just redo this little thing but change
the text to a lot of [__] lives of
being sex trafficking stuff
wow guys she must be funny she must be a
lot of fun at rap video shoots
[Music]
so she's just like somebody that's been
trying to make it forever huh yes yes
she has a pathological need to be famous
she is just the F and so this is the
absolute worst merch you're one of the
first people to to really fun really lay
into this to give Marshall his [__]
detector was was [__] through the
roof with her
um and I figured we'd play this trailer
because I like I
immerses in it obviously but uh fair and
balance is uh doing a a little little
video on Eliza blue here check out the
trailer
it was exactly what
sort of organizations are available to
help people I'm one of those survivors
that prefers uh given the opportunity
I'm sorry to me to pause but I do have
to it's not because my audio thing is
it's bugging me now Eliza If you're
doing an interview
you need headphones on because it's not
it's gonna Dr Drew is going to Echo back
like he's doing because you're stupid
to be free I don't understand so there's
someone creates a fake profile of you
and that's how they would traffic me
sell me without my full consent so this
is the kind of identity theft kind of
situation too inconsistent too all over
the place it's around the same time she
said she was being sex trafficked
doesn't really look like sex trafficking
to me you're twerking you're humping the
floor you're showing your tits it looks
like the uh the internet is completely
turning 100 against her what's been your
strangest booking request so far
sex
y
that I'm sorry
yeah I already was offering you that
um that's a lot of money
she's never mentioned any of this
therefore she's either lying about the
past or she's lying about now either way
one way or another this is an expose an
individual who has a large social media
following as well as the ear of Elon
Musk Elon Musk Elon Musk who's still
being quiet please keep it in his mouth
shut and and running and still carrying
her water
Brittany oh you oh actually you know
what I just thought about it I think I
know why Elon Musk isn't saying anything
because he's [__] [__] no because
like one of the like a couple of like
the major shipping [__] uh carriers
for Europe have just said that they're
not going to be shipping electric cars
on their ships anymore because of all
the [__] fires oh yeah that's not the
best so so like Tesla's stock is [__]
plummeting actually it's up
oh my God it's way up today holy [__]
that's because they're they're they're
they're they're letting them ship it now
because he said if not he there there
were sex trafficking him
oh okay
sex traffic Teslas I know they had
record uh earnings and everything I knew
that do remember I said a few weeks ago
the Tesla [__] is all [__] I'm gonna
pick up some Tesla right uh so now it's
at uh it's like a hundred it's 160 a
share and I got it at like 115 a share
no [__]
I have been locked out of my account on
Twitter Brittany benty who is also a
human trafficking Advocate hey Eliza
blue the sensation
when was Brittany Fenty ever a human
trafficking this is why I hate this this
is why I hate this this is why I didn't
go on that [__] stream last night
because I can't it's like everyone
thinks you just pick a side and you know
like Hey we're all gonna pile on this
[__] but no I'm not gonna let you get
away with your [__] either what did
Brittany venti do for human trafficking
uh
uh man these [__] man they they
tell the truth and lie in the same set I
hate it yeah man I hate it I hate our
business it's great when you you know
let me tell you something buddy I'm a
cheeseburger Advocate big fan so I'm an
advocate of cheeseburgers now from now
on I'm an advocate for them
no you just enjoy them nah well that's
not what my Twitter bio says just like
just like Brittany benty enjoys sex
trafficking you know what I'm an
advocate of titties do you know what
there you go you know what please donate
to the cause at Joy of Patsy when was
Britney venti ever gone at length to
fight trafficking
I don't know
so why did this person say why can't
these people just stay on [__] point
without sucking dick at somebody with
more followers about being traffic but
I'm hoping you could clarify a thread
this was the reasoning privately no
mercy should be a lot more popular if
you'd stop asking so many good [__]
questions you know but like you get my
point this is why it's very funny oh
this is my last night dude like you know
look full disclosure some of the fans
were bitching because that Star Wars
girl was doing a stream and it was like
quartering and Jeremy Chrissy Mayer wait
that's that boring boring Jeremy boring
Jeremy and a bunch of people were super
chatting and tagging me on Twitter like
yo you should be on this stream this is
[__] [__] and I'm like yeah you
know whatever I was like I don't want to
use people anyway and then uh Chrissy
Mayer was like hey we should get merged
on this stream and they're like sure
whatever but then they were like she was
like oh just behave like don't start I'm
like no I don't behave with any of these
people just because Eliza blue sucks
doesn't mean everybody else is off the
hook by the way
Bianca zombie said Brittany helped love
the Balenciaga story so did we
up up
the Balenciaga story was not a lot of
people were on that yeah okay and she
didn't Discover it and if anything the
biggest person that [__] uh signal
boosted that was Kanye oh I'm so sick of
this [__] actually you know she's the
one that she didn't do [__]
tweeted about it like the rest of us
stop doing this
distributed intimate media
um I don't like to go into too much
detail you're seeing somebody supremely
comfortable basically wearing a bustier
and then you got somebody that's like I
don't know what the heck what she was
wearing and it's like you're dealing
with two different people more Sinister
um details have come out around not only
my current generous yeah a fellow
content creator Brittany bentian who
have posted a publicly available photo
this whole uh allowing the system to be
gained for people close to him it seems
very suspicious yeah I'm really into
hold on wait a second we did do that
dramatic reading of quartering asking
will you send it to me again yes
oh my God yeah and now he's like now
he's gone from that to elon's not good
oh boy you're it's a really good point
that was a quick turnaround huh
real quick turnaround pump the [__]
brakes huh in the moment he goes back to
doing something the quartering like so
suck his [__] dick again
that's a really good point you know what
Jeremy listen I'm just like you buddy
you know what when I when I get rejected
sexually by somebody I might stop you
know doing [__] running interference
for them too I get it buddy
well that's really specific I mean
that's like
yeah
[Laughter]
obviously
which has to go to lazapu tonight to
help human trafficking victims and to
raise awareness trafficking victim
that's gonna help with me and I'm here
with trafficking Survivor but so the
money goes directly to her by the way I
love that oh I get half of the [__]
super chats and they go right to me let
me tell you what I can help by number
one I don't have internet anybody that
feels a need to contact me personally
can text message me through a service
called chat star wait chat star is a cam
site Hold Up Wait what I won't ask
I won't ask those people to change their
opinion for ourselves we know Mercy is
in it you can stop saying it take I
would just ask them to consider one
thing what if you're wrong is it
possible
what if I'm right though
when it comes First
Merch with the Stinger of the trailer
the dramatic pause
love it but what if I'm right though
good job Marsh good job I'm good I'm
good for trailers you real dude merch
I'm trailer boys if you ever need you
ever look for like a side Hustle Man
just do trailer voices like coming soon
that's my new that's my new uh my new
persona because I'm like Chris Jericho
you know I got so many personas I got Mr
some days off yeah I like that now now
and you got the night Daddy and now
leader of the Judas goats and now we
have uh trailer boy I'm sorry I like
trailer boy
my friend merch is being humble he's a
sex trafficking Advocate
um
yeah change your bio please to sex
trafficking Advocate put your put your
pronouns